Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As you see, this is not our usual intro.
Why is that? Because today we are going
simulate the process of real painting
on a computer, and we’ll find out that
all previous techniques mix paint incorrectly,
and finally, and create this beautiful image.
Now, there are plenty of previous
techniques that help us paint
digitally, so, why do we
need a new paper for this?
Well, believe it or not, these previous methods
think differently about the shape that the
paint has to take, the more sophisticated
ones even simulate the diffusion of paint,
which is fantastic. They all do these things a
little differently, but they agree on one thing.
And, here comes the problem. The one thing
they agree on is that blue plus yellow equals
a creamy color. But, wait a second… let’s
actually try this. Many of you know already what
is coming…of course. In real life, blue plus
yellow is not a creamy color, it is green.
Does the new method know this?
Yes it does! But only this one.
And we can try the similar experiments over and
over and over again. The results are the same.
So, how is this even possible? Does no one
know that blue plus yellow equals green?
Well, of course they know, but a
proper simulation of pigments mixing
is very challenging. For instance, it requires
keeping track of pigment concentrations, and
we also have to simulate subsurface
scattering, which is the absorption
and scattering of light within a volume of
these pigments. In some critical applications,
just this part can take several hours to days
to compute for a challenging case. And now,
hold on to your papers, because this new technique
can do all this correctly, and in real time. I
loved this visualization as it is really dense
in information, and super easy to read at the
same time. That is quite a challenge, and in my
opinion, just this one figure could win an award
by itself. As you see, most of the time, it runs
easily with 60, or higher frames per second,
and even in the craziest cases, it can compute all
this about 30 times per second. That is insanity.
So, what do we get for all this effort? A
more realistic digital painting experience.
For instance, with the new method, color
mixing now feels absolutely amazing,
and if we feel like applying a ton of paint
and let it stain the paper, we get something
much more lifelike too. Artists who try this
will appreciate these a great deal I am sure.
Especially that the authors also made this paint
color mixing technique available for everyone,
free of charge. As we noted, computing this kind
of paint mixing simulation is not easy, however,
using the final technique is, on the other
hand, extremely easy. As easy as it gets. If
you feel like coding up a simulation and include
this method in it, this is all you need to do.
Very few paper implementations are this simple to
use. It conceals all the mathematical difficulties
away from you. Extra point for elegance,
and, huge congratulations to the authors!
Now, after nearly every Two Minute
Papers episode where we showcase
such an amazing paper, I get a question saying
something like “okay, but when do I get to see
or use this in the real world?”. And rightfully
so, that is a good question. For instance,
this previous GauGAN paper was
published in 2019, and here we are,
just a bit more than 2 years later, and it
has been transferred into a real product.
Some machine learning papers also made it to
Tesla’s self driving cars in one or two years,
so tech transfer from research to real products
is real. But, is it real with this technique?
Yes it is! So much so that it is already available
in an app name Rebelle 5, which offers a
next level digital painting experience.
It even simulates different kinds
of papers and how they absorb paint.
A paper simulation you say? Yes, here, at Two
Minute Papers, we appreciate that a great deal.
If you use this to paint something, please
make sure to leave a comment or tweet at me.
I would love to see your scholarly
paintings! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!